voilà
pour soir messieurs vous me direz que ce
n'est pas très génialement facettes au
moins polis
eh bien merci andré tv je vois qu'il ya
de l'ambiance et il y à aussi de
l'ambiance dans la salle parce que vous
je vois que la télévision régionale
auvergnate porte ses fruits car deux ou
trois petits appels ont suffi à garnir
admirablement cette salle est ce que
vous êtes prêts voulez vous s'il vous
plaît mon cher bob leclerc veut
allo
à l'eau tiède c'est un gag bon sens mais
d'amour en somme et l'oise elle vend
sont messieurs après nos actualités vous
allez pouvoir regarder notre émission
culinaire avec raymond oliver voici
maintenant les prévisions
météorologiques pour la journée du 24
octobre le temps sera généralement beau
sur la moitié nord du massif central
il y aura quelques averses venant de
l'ouest
le vent de secteur sud se tournera vers
ce secteur sud-ouest et aura une vitesse
de 60 à 70 km heure mesdames messieurs
après être resté dans studio nous allons
passer ces quelques instants en auvergne